listen if you don't travel if you don't
meet different people if you don't see
different cultures
your knowledge isn't going to be great
about what the [ __ ] happening in the
world
or what other people are like so then
what happens you have a kid what the
[ __ ] are you going to teach that kid
what are you going to teach that kid
what have you seen you know like you
live in england you got a british
passport
you've got the luxury to travel the
world and you're telling me you're not
going to take advantage of that it's
crazy i know
people yeah in turkey that would kill
for a british passport just so they can
travel
diren bloody cartel how are you my
friend
i'm excited to be here man i'm not gonna
lie i was disappointed you didn't have a
studio lined up for me in dubai but i
don't want to talk about that
a little bit of a different environment
to the last time that we were together
on a boat outside the burj
al-arab bro how good was that day
i was hanging i was hanging but
it was such a good day man it's just a
vitamin d man it's good for everything
it it it solves all problems that's one
hell of a wake-up call you get up at
finally sort of surface half past 10 in
the morning and you've got a couple of
whatsapp saying you have 45 minutes to
get ready i need to see you down at the
marina because we're getting on a boat
for the next five hours
brother yeah i got the same if i didn't
i didn't know i was like yeah we're
going here we're meeting
with who with the boys with the guys you
know and those guys are crazy man
those guys can drink for days and i i'm
just i'm just such
a lightweight that like
which i'm proud of by the way everyone's
like oh yeah i'm like i'm proud of him
like oh you're lightweight i'm like
yeah bro so what have you achieved by
saying that i don't care but it was it
was a great time it was a great time
those lads are funny people
yeah they are man it's when you get that
group of people together it's uh
it's a recipe for chaos so today i
wanted to talk about motivation
so we're approaching a new year people
are going to be making resolutions
wanting to change their routines this is
a lot of what you do with your work
my people might even be looking to
change their lives you know create the
foundations upon which their new life is
going to be built what are the
principles that you give your clients
when they want to make big changes in
their lives
so i think one thing is um a lot of
people come to me for fitness and
nutrition right because
in essence i'm a personal trainer but
what i've realized is the program that i
do and the way i train people and do
things with my clients
i've actually realized it affects their
normal life as well as their health
because in essence when you look after
your health
other things around your life actually
become a lot better and i think
one of the key things about trying to
keep my clients motivated
is trying to get them to do something
that they really enjoy
which i think is one of the biggest
issues people feel like
you need to be consistently struggling
to be to achieve whether it's a fitness
goal whether it's whatever you want to
do in life
you know and and i try to make what they
see
a big problem a small one
because i feel like when we look at
problems as a small issue
and look at solving them the stress
about being motivated or whatever
you're trying to solve kind of goes away
does that does that make sense do you
get what i'm trying to say there
yeah man so talk me through someone
comes to you and they say
hey coach i'm wanting to do x i really
want to
get a black belt in jiu jitsu i really
want to
lose 50 pounds or 20 pounds or
get in shape for whatever it might be
but i don't really feel that motivated
to do it
should they just drop it no of course
not they should i think they should they
need to ask themselves
like why they're doing it you know why
they're doing it what they want to
achieve from it
and what they need to understand is to
achieve
to achieve whatever they want to achieve
there's certain steps that you need to
go through so if it's fitness
for example you're coming to me for
fitness i'm going to teach you the basic
fundamentals i'm going to simplify it in
such a way to you
that you're not going to see it as a
problem because i think
at the moment with coaches with
personal training i feel like the
delivery of the coach
chatting to someone is really important
so if i'm chatting to you
i need to be talking to you in a
language that you're going to understand
you know i need to make sure whatever
i'm saying to you or how i'm delivering
it to you
you need to be paying attention you know
it's um
it's one of those things where because i
do like group coaching at the minute
um each individual is very different
but if you look at it as a group we all
have
very similar problems it's just you kind
of have to word things differently
talking to different individuals
what are the most common problems that
you see coming up
bro at the minute mental health man like
at the minute it's like a lot of mental
health and obviously with the pandemic
not being able to travel as freely as we
want to i see a lot of people
worrying about tomorrow worrying about
what's going to happen
instead of worrying about today and
i think one thing that we all need to do
is what i do is i'm not worrying about
tomorrow
i'm worried about this podcast today
what's the point of me worrying about it
for a week you know not that i was
worrying about it but like
what am i gonna over plan what am i
gonna why should i worry about what i'm
gonna talk about
i'm gonna talk about whatever feels good
i'm gonna deal with it however i'm
feeling today
and i'm gonna take the challenge or
whatever it is
in a way that i feel because to be
honest i love doing podcasts man i love
these conversations i feel like it's one
of the
best ways i learn you're probably the
same you're probably similar right
absolutely man one of the things i
learned from a guy called andrew tate
who is a
son of a chess grandmaster he's a
kickboxing world champion he lives in a
basically a fortress in romania and he's
a millionaire
he's like just a very very eccentric
fella and um
he has this concept where he says he has
faith
that future andrew will will save more
money
so he'll go out and he'll buy bugatti
because he knows that future andrew will
earn the money to pay for it
and this kind of unrelenting faith in
the future version of you
is something that i i've tried to
cultivate a lot this year
and when you can fully lean into it and
actually believe it not just say it but
you know genuinely
in the source code it's written into
your being when
you realize or when you hopefully take
that in
it makes a very big difference but i
think if you don't
have sufficient situations during which
you have proven to yourself that you can
actually perform that you can make a
promise and then deliver it to you
understandably you have low confidence
and if you have low confidence you're
going to be concerned about tomorrow
because well i yesterday i was concerned
about today and today i didn't do what i
said i was going to do yesterday
so tomorrow what if i say that don't do
the thing that i say i'm going to do
today and
this is how we get into that cycle right
but you know what it is it's it's
that thing you're talking about is um
the people that can't do that are too
worried about being
safe right the safety element so for
example
but i was buying business class tickets
with james smith when i couldn't afford
it
you know thinking well don't worry about
doing just buy this
your money is going to be you're going
to have barely anything in your bank
account but
future durian is going to make that
don't worry just
get on that flight get in that
environment get with those people don't
worry about tomorrow worry about today
and then we'll deal with
uh tomorrow then and we'll tackle that
then and it's
people need to take their mind depending
on what they want to achieve like if
you're happy with where you are of
course
like do what you need to do but if
you're not and if you want to achieve
certain things i feel like
you need to take some risks and the only
time
you perform is when you have no other
[ __ ] option
you know if if you have one chance if
you said you're going to deliver
something right
and you have the only opportunity for
for you to have a good outcome of this
is
delivering whatever you're delivering
well you're going to turn up
especially if you need the money
especially if you don't want to
disappoint people
and especially if you if you don't want
to fail i mean the fear of failing kind
of
like it you shouldn't be scared of
failing but
it also gets you doing what you're
supposed to do as well
right perfect example of that i think
james would admit when he started
writing his first book
like he's not an author i'm aware that
he's a two times sunday times best
seller now
but when he began writing his first book
he wasn't an author and he wasn't
getting it goals written he was doing it
himself
and as soon as you sign on the dirty
line with harper collins
it's like okay they expect a book and
holy [ __ ] this needs to be done in the
next nine months
i need to i need to put some words to
paper
and you will find a way to do it i would
say
in my experience most people
underestimate their capacities moving
forward
fewer people are overconfident than
underconfident in my experience
bro i think a lot of people um
me your environment and who you're
around is so important
but it's so important and the people
that
tend to say not make the leap with
whatever it is that they want to do
is kind of around people that says yeah
yeah yeah maybe don't risk it no no no
no play it safe
play it safe or they say it because they
don't want you to
be better than them essentially you know
i like to be around people that want the
best for me want me to win
you know and i like to keep people
around me that are like that and i'm
only around those sort of people because
i feel like that's the only way to kind
of push each other and in a
in a with the right pressure
as well as with the right people around
you when
if you need something you can ask and
you know they're there to um
either give you advice either push you
more or tell you that
hey different that content was [ __ ] bro
what are you doing
you know and i get that like we have a
group chat with the boys and we'll
message him then we'll be like yo bro
hey i'm not gonna lie to you man that
was probably the worst thing i've ever
seen in my life
you know and then next week you know
you've got four of your mates grilling
you
so hard about it a bit of tough love the
next day
bang 50 000 views on a video or whatever
it is you know
and i feel like it's just so important
to have the right people around you
which i think
most people don't have if i'm being
honest do you think that's a
byproduct of british culture
you know what it's hard for me to answer
that because
although i am in british culture i'm
very much like my dad
who's a kurd in turkey and i've always
been around
very um i've always been around africans
um jamaicans turks because i've been
around british culture but i've also
been
in the heart of london where it's so
mixed that i i'm not even sure what the
answer to that question
is if that makes sense no i know what
you mean i have a theory that i've been
working on this
this year that is because
geographically the uk is water locked
right it gives people a very kind of
insulated sense of life i don't know
i can't speak for what it's like in
france or in germany or in america or
anywhere else
but i know for a fact that there are
tons and tons and tons of people that i
went to
state primary state secondary state
college with
who are going to be born live and die
in the town that they came up in so
stockton on teas which is a
a lovely place and mom and dad are still
there and they love it
um but is famous only for having the
uk's highest
teen pregnancy rating uh and they
recently they recently lost that as well
so that
that was one thing they had that's now
gone um and i remember
i was like 15 years old or 14 years old
in some older buddies car from college
or something
and we were driving around and i
remember one of the kids that was sat in
the back
saying as we're going over this flyover
in on the a19 in t side
i remember him saying then t-side's the
best place in the world man
i'm never gonna leave and i thought even
then i'd never been anywhere except for
like
disneyland with mum and dad and
lanzarote and stuff and i remember
thinking then
that is unbelievably short-sighted
and i worry about what sort of an
influence that has
for other people who perhaps have goals
who want to grow who want to do other
things
don't get me wrong it makes for a
fantastic family life i think it
promotes a classic sort of
british dream growing up having a family
you know doing that sort of thing
but for an entrepreneur somebody who
wants to grow and experience new things
i'm not convinced it's the best
environment i i don't think it's best
for family either if i'm being honest
that's because and the only reason i say
that is listen if you don't travel if
you don't meet different people if you
don't see different cultures
i'm sorry but you're not going to be
your knowledge isn't going to be great
about what the [ __ ] happening in the
world
or what other people are like so then
what happens
you have a kid what the [ __ ] are you
gonna teach that kid
what are you gonna teach that kid you
what have you seen
you know like you live in england you've
got a british passport you've got the
luxury to travel
the world and you're telling me you're
not gonna take advantage of that it's
crazy
i know people yeah in turkey that would
kill
for a british passport just so they can
travel you know not just turkey loads of
countries
right and i feel like people don't
realize how lucky
i think we have it in england with the
opportunities that we have
uh with the traveling that we could do
obviously not with a pandemic and all
that happening
but it's i think it's so important that
if you can travel
you should and it's not just for you
it's for people
around you your eyes will open
differently and this is like
maybe the hippie side of me coming out
that's lived in bali lived in australia
lived in turkey
and all that but my best skill is
probably the fact that i can socialize
with
anyone anyone i can hold a conversation
with anyone and i know for a fact
that's only happened because i've always
been in awkward positions
in different countries where i don't
even speak the language but somehow
i got out of that situation or whatever
it is you know
and like you for example you said you
didn't travel much but you go into
lanzarote you go to disneyland wherever
it is
you saw something different that you
wanted to see more of
and that's thanks to your family right
you might not be in dubai right now
doing a podcast which you love doing
if your family didn't initially take you
on a holiday it doesn't matter if they
went on a holiday and had a
english breakfast in the morning but
i think it's i think it's really
important that you take advantage of
traveling and it's fun man
it's it's so much fun do you like you
like it right i mean you're in dubai
no i'm not this is me back home i'm back
home now but um yeah back home
yeah last year was last year was 12
countries this year
even with the pandemic did athens for my
birthday
ibiza when you were there and then um
dubai dubai when you were there as well
you know this is something that i
thought that was really funny i was like
yeah
i'm trailblazing you know even during
the pandemic i'm being anti-fragile i'm
finding myself places that i can go to
i'm like i'm so unique like this is and
then in each one of those places
you were there and then and then
mike thurston was there as well and i
was like oh maybe
maybe i'm a little bit less unique than
i thought but you know what yeah
it's um isn't it amazing like when you
like you get on a plane they're signing
about
they're signing airports that really are
just buzz i'll buzz it i'm in the
airport i'm excited i can't wait to open
up my laptop
write an email do a bit of work maybe
have a beer like
i'll buzz off it get on a flight and
then
you get off whether it's a hot country
or not you're somewhere different
it sparks so many different ideas
that you can do for content business
meeting new people whatever it is so
many new opportunities
and initially doing that i think it's
because at 16 i went away and
i played football in turkey so i think
from a young age i was very used to
kind of traveling on my own so
maybe i got rid of that fear early on
and i think some people
might be worried because oh [ __ ] i'm 30
years old i'm too late to
travel i'm too late to do this when
you're not man it's never too late
dave driscoll is 42 and that man's still
getting naked every morning and then
going and running wanderlust's
uh crossfit brother he's in ridiculous
shape for his
you know he's in ridiculous shape mate
such a good looking guy as well man
so much charisma me he's exactly human
charisma here's one thing that yeah yeah
he's a good guy
i realized after dubai i put it in my
email that went out today
um you know ollie allison right you part
of our little
cabal of of guys that luke knows and
he taught me about break point which is
in the sas
they'll land somewhere and they'll
either fight or sneak their way to an
objective
let's say that they're going to breach a
room and before they breach the room
they'll stack up outside of the door so
you can imagine like proper tom clancy
rainbow six
[ __ ] and they're stacked up outside of
the door and they take a moment while
they're there
they just breathe reset recalibrate
they take themselves through the plan
that's going to come up
and then they breach the room and it's
this interlude between two periods of
chaos right so you've got two periods of
intense action and you have this one
period
that just gives you a chance where you
can move between the two
and i was in dubai for three and a half
weeks which is the longest i've been
anywhere
uh in quite a while last year i did a
road trip across america which was a
similar amount of time
um but i was still working while i was
out in dubai so recording the show still
doing all of this stuff
and i came back and honestly last week
was the best that my mindset's been in
the uk
in pretty much as long as i can remember
and obviously i was curious as to why
that was the case i'm thinking like what
have i done
was it that i got some sunshine was it
just like
defeating a little bit of seasonal
affective disorder because it's so dark
and cold and gray here
and what i came to is i think it was
like a personal break point
that i went away and it was just an
opportunity to see something different
it was an interlude between two periods
that were very similar and very chaotic
so everyone this year has spent
groundhog day over and over again
looking at the same four walls right
move had its busiest ever day in history
for properties just toward the end of
the first lockdown
because people are sick of the houses
that they're in they've realized that
i hate not having a car a garden i hate
the partner that i'm living with so i'm
going to split up with them whatever it
might be
tons of houses got listed tons of people
wanted to move so yeah
the what i took away from it was that
being away
still working still doing what i do but
in a new environment new stimulus
seeing yourself seeing all my buddies
out there going and seeing mk play live
going and
you know all of these different
experiences had given me an opportunity
to come back with a fresh set of eyes
and new clarity
and if that's not a good advertisement
for travel
i'm not really sure what is bro i mean
think about it like this
i spoke to you we spoke a bit on them
on the boat right that day and when i
spoke to you i was like
i'm writing what are you doing with your
podcast mate every day you've got an
episode you've got something happening i
rate i rate how organized you are
and i was like i need to do more [ __ ]
episodes
you know like it sounds crazy but this
is how i think
maybe me being in dubai or whatever me
just chatting to you for like 5-10
minutes
is gonna push me to do another 20 or 30
episodes
in the next six months that 20 30
episodes can help so many people
that 20 30 episodes can help my growth
or whatever it is
you know and i think that's that's why i
love traveling so much man
and there's something about being
somewhere different
and talking to someone right
it's like every sort of
whether it's ego that you have back at
home whether it's the comfort that you
have whether it's the fact that you know
you can
swing your dick around and talk freely
because you know your friends around the
corner
when you're away you're nicer
people are nicer when they're away you
know when you're not in your hometown
you know to be nice because
well you've got no other option and that
guy might have eight massive mates
yeah exactly so it's like it's just such
a nice environment
to see people and connect with people
you know but um
i love dubai was great man and it's good
to see that
you did that traveling as well and it's
good to see that's helping you out bro i
love it i love it
it really is one of the things that i
hate that
really really irks me and i think this
is part of that british culture thing
is when i'll hear someone make a
pejorative statement about
america americans or australians or
turkish people or french or whatever it
is and i know for a fact
that they've never been to that country
it's like
what what are you talking about how can
you say that you've lived in
westerhope just north of newcastle for
the last
27 years and now you think that you an
authority on
all of these different countries bro
it's mad you know because like
you get i know i know like people
because i've i've had like few dm's i've
had a few trolls like troll me right
and like i just know when it's racist i
know i can feel it man i can feel it
like
they'll say something about the way i
talk or something and i feel it man and
i see it
and i don't doubt myself one bit and i'm
like you prick
but you're there you say something like
that to me but then you go to the kebab
shop and then you order food from there
you know like how does that even like
what what goes in your racist mind
and then you go and order a kebab from a
turkish man you know it's funny and
it's i guess it's mad in it like the
whole brexit thing i don't know like
people don't even know what they're
voting for people don't know what
they're doing people don't know
uh what's even good for them
i swear to god people some people don't
even know what's good for them so
they're kind of
doing what everyone else is doing or
what they're provoked to say or what
they're provoked
to decide you know it's a bit scary
actually how
media and everything can manipulate so
many people it's
it's [ __ ] terrifying man it's
absolutely terrifying especially when
you think so going back to what we were
talking about there about motivation and
people losing motivation with certain
things
you have to consider that a lot of
people don't do
things they want to do they do things
that they think they want to do
and the things that they think that they
want to do very often
are values that they've adopted from
their parents from their friends
from their culture from their local town
whatever it might be but these
aren't consciously designed decisions
these are things
that they've like a [ __ ] dirty sponge
just absorbed and then made the lowest
common denominator of that
like how many guys do you know that do
purely bodybuilding style programming
because that's all that their mates do
but if they were to take up
endurance racing or bjj or crossfit or
functional fitness or
yoga or pilates or whatever it might be
they'll be so much happier they'd be so
much more compliant with training they'd
be fitted they'd be healthier all of
this stuff
but they'll continue to grind away
because all that they know
is bodybuilding yeah it's um
it's mad and i think one of the one of
the problems
is i'll tell you what it is is when
people
if people don't know if you don't know
what you're supposed to do yeah if
you're listening to this if you don't
know what you're what you're supposed to
do
if you don't know what you want to do
that's fine like that's okay
to not know right because i'm not going
to lie to you i'm kind of kicking with
the wind i'm loving what i'm doing
but i don't know what i'm going to do in
five years i don't know what i'm going
to do in 10 years
i might [ __ ] hate doing podcasts on
social media and pt
i might do something i might be selling
cars i don't know you know
and people worry so much about
uh feeling either
not a part of something or feeling like
not doing anything is a waste of time
because they're judged
if you don't for example if you don't
have a job or whatever it is or if you
don't have a job where you wake up at
4am and you don't work 14 hours it's
like oh you don't know what hard work is
like i'm not shut the [ __ ] up bro
i mean just because you work hard
doesn't mean you're like
you're actually working efficiently
you're actually doing something that's
making a big difference you know so for
people that are worrying
about not knowing what to do i mean
that's okay like
that's okay don't force something you
don't like or what
someone else has told you to do because
you don't know
there's a paradigm that james clear uses
called
explore exploit and his argument is
that earlier on in your life or in
periods where you're finding yourself a
little bit lost
you should explore you should do lots of
different things
travel is a perfect example of that go
and join a new sports club
go and join try out a new hobby go to a
public speaking event
go to like just mad stuff just say yes
to adventures
because coming out of those adventures
you will probably
learn so much so quickly about what it
is that you do and don't like
that you're then able to exploit ie
narrow down into the channels of stuff
that you do like
so much more quickly but again people
have these fears i don't want to do
something new what if i suck what if i'm
silly what if nobody likes me
so they don't they just stick to doing
that same habitual stuff
that's mate the biggest issue is uh
people worrying about what other people
think that's that is what stops everyone
how do you get past that
how did i get past it how did i get past
it
i got past it to be honest i kind of got
past it looking at how my dad is
my dad says what he my dad says what he
thinks and i know he gets him into a lot
of trouble
but it also gets him to a lot of good
places and i was like
i need to stop being because i played
football right for a very long time
and i think one of the reasons i wasn't
successful is i was a bit nervous on the
pitch
and i think i cared too much i cared if
i make a mistake
the coach is not going to play me again
i cared that
if i passed the ball wrong or whatever
that play is not gonna pass the ball
again to me i cared too much
and i was like instead of worrying about
what people are gonna think about
whatever i'm doing i just need to worry
about doing
the job that i'm supposed to do and
doing what i'm enjoying and actually
concentrating on just myself
instead of basing any decision that i
make on anyone
any decision that i make now is based on
what i want to do like i will sit
somewhere with my mom and dad sometimes
they've
sometimes they would drag me to family
meets i'm like mom i'm going i've
ordered a new bar
what are you doing i'm like i'm not
happy here i want to go this is wasting
my time
i've said hello to everyone i've spoke
to people
um i've showed my respect i've catched
up with
everyone i'm going i'm wasting my time
i'll rather be on my laptop at the
minute
and do something productive you know so
i'm basing every decision
on what is best for me and that is kind
of helps me pass through that
if that makes sense you said in a
podcast recently that people like you
more now that you're being selfish
yeah yeah i'm guessing that's this i'm
guessing yeah i think yeah
people like me more people people kind
of like i even know people don't ask me
for stuff because
people don't ask me for stuff they know
i'm not going to say yes to you
they're like i know like my cousin would
be like should we ask it now probably
not he ain't going to come he knows we
know he ain't going to come
you know because he's got his thing he
needs to do they know
because when i'm there or when i'm doing
something they know because i truly want
to do it
you know like again i'm going to give
smith as an example
he knows me i'm flying to australia i'm
going to do two weeks quarantine in a
room
in essence i'm going for his tour right
but he knows
that i'm going for me as well because
it's going to make me happy
you know so there's no feeling of where
he's going to feel guilty because oh
[ __ ] i've made darren
uh stay in a room or not he knows
darren's coming because it's gonna make
him happy
you know and it's the same vice versa
with him or with anyone you know that's
why people just need to prioritize
and not be afraid to be selfish being
selfish isn't bad man
being selfish is being selfish is
is good because it's good because in the
long run not even in the long run like
it doesn't have to be that long
you make other people around you way
happier because
you're happier because you're doing what
you like
what you want to do you know yeah that
confidence i think is born out
of someone who has a very very strong
why
if you've got a strong enough why i know
what i want to do
then everything else is going to move
out of the way because it has to
but so much of our time and this is
something that i've only learned in the
last couple of years
it's very very rare that we actually sit
back and assess
how are we doing our lives how are we
spending our lives what are our values
it took me until i was 31 years old
to define my core values in life sat
down spent two days doing taylor
pearson's core values exercise which
everyone who's listening will be
familiar with and if you're not
search tail appears and core values
it'll take you probably half a day but
it took me two days
um and i sat down and did that and i was
like i've lived my life for 31 years
yeah without knowing what the basis
values that i
live on are and then as soon as that
happened as soon as i realized what they
are curiosity adventure selfless
development excellence and self-care
i'm like okay everything that i do in my
life serves these five things one of
these five things are multiple within it
it made everything else easier but
because
i was so caught up with the important
tasks sorry with the urgent tasks
i never got to the important ones
answering emails spending too much time
on my phone just being busy responding
to people whatever it might be just
[ __ ] about wasting time on stuff that
doesn't properly move the needle
as soon as i did the difference
downstream from that
is night and day mate it's like
a small example is
this i've got three i've got four
[ __ ] not three
four five five notifications already
right like on my phone
i'm not gonna [ __ ] reply to him till
somewhere you know because i've got [ __ ]
to do
and i feel like so many people feel the
pressure of oh [ __ ]
i need to reply right now i need to
reply right now and they lose valuable
time
you know which is so important to
focus on yourself and what you're trying
to do instead of again worrying about
other people's problems because a lot of
the time
people are just bitching instead of
getting things done
you know i think think as well if you've
got such a weak
why if your goal your end goal that you
want to achieve is so poorly defined
and doesn't have any affinity to who you
truly are you're going to answer the
text
yeah because why wouldn't you you've got
nothing better to do
whereas if you spend that time i'm going
to explore before i exploit i'm going to
try new things i'm going to work out
something that i love and then i'm going
to
really really get into it i'm going to
find out who i
am and then i'm going to commit myself
to being the best version of that person
that i can be
if you do that you're not even going to
notice the messages
you're not even you're not even going to
realize that the notifications have come
people are going to ask you to come to
the [ __ ] that's important but not the
other stuff
because they know that you're on your
path and as well as a final thing
you i think that you're right that some
people are nervous about
uh not compromising what they do to keep
other people happy
but think yourself who is it that you're
most gravitated towards who is it that
has that
real social gravitas that renown it's
people who are on a journey who have a
mission
that's who compels you why do people
listen to james
it's because he is a guy who has his
very very very clearly defined values
bright lines in the sand about what you
will and won't accept
and he's iterated on that a thousand
times in different posts and videos and
live streams
so people resonate with a person who is
on the journey more than they resonate
with someone who compromises their
values at the first moment to make them
happy
yeah that's it that's exactly right it's
funny when when we do a lot of traveling
and stuff like
we become we will have very
careful with kind of not not careful
like with who we hang around but anyone
that
kind of hangs with us they end up
becoming friends and
very quickly you see like the influence
on what now they
they get influenced so much they start
[ __ ] wanting to do
this and i love it it's so good to see
someone like kind of
evolve like that you know it's such a
powerful thing and you're right we are
your grand and you can feel it in a room
when someone walks in
you can feel the energy bang they're
like oh i don't know what he's doing
i don't i don't know what it is but it
feels right
bro so here's a perfect example of that
i'm in dubai
and i'm going out for dinner with george
the buddy that i was out there with
he used to work for social chain big
social media companies and used to be
owned by the ceo stephen bartlett
so steven's diary of a ceo quite sort of
big time now
and has just become on the board of huel
so we're going in for dinner in this
private dining room in sailor v on the
54th
floor of this huge tower overlooking the
birch
right in downtown dubai crazy expensive
restaurant
beautiful we walk in and we sat down in
this room and it's an
oval table right so
everyone's facing inward but i noticed i
sat down and after about sort of 20
minutes or so everyone everybody's
sat in there and steve's there and his
manager and his video guy and his social
media manager and his assistant and me
and my mate and a couple of other people
and i noticed that even though it's an
oval table everybody had subtly shifted
their chairs slightly toward him so he
was at the head of the table
even though it was circular he was at
the head of the table and he was the guy
that was commanding the room
even though it wasn't a work meeting he
wasn't there with like to control or
even do business but everybody had
subtly moved themselves and i was like
that's such an interesting symbolic
representation
of where the gravity is coming from
where the power lies within this room
he's leader you know and you can feel
you can feel that with some people it's
just
with some people it's a natural thing
man you know it's a natural thing and
i think it's i feel like it's something
that
you have like you said when you know
your wife right
or you naturally have it some people
naturally have it
and some people have it because of what
they do and knowing what they're doing
i get i i get really really jealous of
people who've stumbled upon their why
just with no work like it happened you
know you think about any
any sportsman who's done their sport
since they were a kid
like you happened england a couple of
nights ago
won the autumn nations cup like all of
the guys that are playing that game
would probably went down and played kids
rugby at
10 years old or something and then 15
years later
are winning the autumn nations cup on
the biggest stage in the world for
england
like that's not necessarily
their choice to fight they just stumbled
upon it and then they went all in
for other people and i think that's
probably really interesting
an important point for people to
remember that those people that you see
yes they are living their why yes
they're bearing a very difficult and
hardworking and
emphatic how but that's not the same as
you just because they didn't have to
work at finding their why they found it
when they were 10 years old somehow
doesn't mean that you shouldn't compare
yourself to them
they're an international level athlete
that's played this sport since they were
a child they probably can't remember
life without playing this sport
or a musician you know that's come about
and was naturally talented and sang or
a dancer or anybody that's done
something from when they were young
perhaps you have to work perhaps the
price that you have to pay to find your
why
yeah is by putting the work in yeah 100
and i think i think that happens quite a
lot because
i think parenting comes into play there
you know i think it's really important i
i know when i'm a parrot one day
hopefully one day
i will know where my kids playing that
is
it's gonna be he's gonna have he's gonna
have my genes
so there's gonna be something in there
that i know i'm gonna recognize
from whether it's the way he or she
moves or what they say
is it's coming from my gene pool right
so
i will know if i see him do something
and they hate it i'm not gonna force him
to do it
you know i feel like smart parenting
will
put and advocate their kids
when they see something that they love
or they love doing and then
they kind of push them towards that
instead of getting them to do things
where um that they dislike like all
those rugby players
their dad or whatever must have been a
rugby fan whatever it is not maybe not
all of them but
majority probably right i started
football because my dad loved football i
saw it for
my dad football you know and um
with them um they didn't
kind of have to work with their wire but
as soon as they found it and they loved
it
they just carried on carried on and it's
pro to those athletes it's not work to
them
you know they hustle hard they know
their why
and which is why they are where they are
you know and like you said it doesn't
matter how old you are wherever it is
if you need to work for it you need to
work for it you need to find it and
anyone can [ __ ] find it it's just if
you say you can't it's just
it's kind of excuses really like you can
it's just excuses
spending enough time as well exposing
yourself to new cultures as we said
earlier on
is such a great way to do it spending
yourself spending your time exposing
yourself to new
uh experiences the number of people who
complain
about not having a purpose or about
being a little bit lost in life
without doing anything new
how would you know but it's like your
judge jury and executioner on a guilty
verdict
it's like hang on a second like i'm
causing this problem and then
complaining about the problem on the
back end
yeah yeah the only way that you're going
to do this is if you do the explore time
100 you need to you need to explore you
need to explore different countries you
need to explore you need to explore
talking to different people like there's
people with the same [ __ ] friend
circle since they were five years old
i'm like well step outside a little bit
meet someone new in it
stop like get out of that little click i
mean if nothing's happening it's
probably your
you're probably not in the right group
if you're the smartest in the room
you're in the wrong room you know just
get out there you know and i think yeah
it's just one of those things i think
people again the fear of changing the
fear of
maybe upsetting people the fear of
what other people think of you yeah you
said something to me that stuck
in dubai you said that calling off an
engagement that you had was one of the
best things
that you ever did in your life can you
can you explain why and take us through
that story
oh basically um i was with the
i was just i was with this i was with
the same girl since i was 17 to like 25
right and she was a good person like a
good person
not had nothing to do with her she was a
great person it was
good timing for her for me it wasn't i
was too young
i i kind of knew my wife i knew my way i
was always
i was always i've always been driven
i've always wanted i wanted to
accomplish big things
um i've never really seen myself or
been lazy whether either if i'm
living in a different country or
whatever it is i always like try to
tackle a problem and
still achieve whatever it is i want to
achieve
but there came a point
where someone else's happiness was
really affecting mine
and i felt like i was like
a part of a show where i wasn't getting
no bonuses
where i wasn't getting paid i was like i
feel like i'm a part of the show
i feel like i'm the main guy of the show
but i'm not getting paid i'm not happy
what's that mean you know oh you're not
happy
i'm not happy yeah like i'm not getting
paid i'm not happy that that that's what
i mean by that
and i wasn't happy i was like hold on
she's happy
their families happy these people are
happy
what the [ __ ] am i doing here why am i
here
what did what did you not happy feel
like what did it mean
it was it was weird i've never
i don't think i've ever been depressed i
kind of don't even know what depressed
it is
you're annoyingly positive darren you're
annoyingly positive that's what you are
uh i know but it's like
i know but i'm not even like i'm not
even trying i know you're not that's
what makes it annoying
yeah i know i know because you know what
there's nothing more annoying than that
[ __ ] positive guy but look at the
part that's you
that's you yeah but honestly i'm not
like
at least you know it's not fake you know
at least you know it's not fake right
and i was trying to look at the
positives and i was like
hold on so this is the moment where i
thought about the future
right when when all this was happening i
was like okay so what i'm gonna get
married
i don't know why the [ __ ] i propose in
the first place i just thought
is pressure from other people pressure
from
her you know hey anyone that's listened
to this any guys
if your partner is telling you broth
looking at rings and giving you subtle
[ __ ] tell them
to be quiet and if if the time is right
if you want to do it you will do it
anyway
you know and it's those sort of
pressures that got to got me to a point
where i was doing taking action
on other people's happiness and other
people's decisions right
and i was so unhappy at that point and i
was like okay let me do some
calculations here
i'm in australia because uh the girl was
australian
uh that's why i had such a connection to
australia that's why i've got residency
in australia
i was in australia i was like okay i'm
living on the suburbs of sydney
not even in the city of sydney i've
moved from the heart of london i'm such
a london city boy
and you've took me to the suburbs where
jimmy billy bob is calling yeah dear and
darren mate and i'm not no it's not
darren it's dyran
man it's [ __ ] different my name is
[ __ ] direct bro
right get it right get it right fan
you know i'm somewhere like somewhere
called the hills
uh the hills area which is like i was in
like balkan hills in sydney and i was
like okay
so i'm gonna get married i'm
probably gonna be forced to have kids
right i want the kids but
there's i want kids when the time is
right i'm gonna buy a house i'm gonna
get a mortgage i had like a deposit
i had a deposit at that point i was 25
man i had a deposit in that i had a
deposit with her in my bank account you
know what i mean
the way spending that after was the best
out of my life i'll get to that in a
minute
so i like sat there and i was i was
doing these calculations and i was like
i don't know when i'm gonna see my
family my family live in
um in london and i'm 24 hours away and
i'm really close with my family i'm
really close with my family and
i know i've got the power to be able to
do things in my life where i can look
after my whole family
which is one of my priorities i want my
sister to live good i want my mom
and my dad to live good you know i want
i want them to experience things that
i've experienced
you know and for me to do that i need an
element of freedom
i need to be able to take off i need to
be able to do
whatever it is i want to do without
basing no decision
or worrying about oh if i say this or if
i do this
it's going to upset this person like i
can't move like that
you know if you want to if you want to
achieve something then there is that bit
of a barrier
right so i was like nah [ __ ] this i
can't do this
ended up calling off a wedding um how
did that conversation go down
bravo it was mad it was mad man
it was i was crying i was upset i
couldn't even
i couldn't even say the words because i
was talking to someone
that was my best friend at the time and
i was talking to someone
trying to tell them that
the problem is not you literally isn't
you it's just that i need to do certain
things in my life to be happy in the
long run
because i don't want to be that 40 year
old that's hiring prostitutes and then
coming home and kissing my wife broth
i didn't want to be that guy and the
truth is
i would have been that guy and i would
have been that guy you know
and i didn't want to be that so
when that conversation went down it was
kind of a conversation where
she knew she kind of said it and i was
like i just need time to think
i need time to think i need to go off
and i i kind of ran away from my
problems a bit that's where i would meet
up 24 7 came up
i was doing like 30 40 30 40 000 steps a
day not to go home it was running from
your engagement
mate running from my problems instead of
tackling them you know and i was younger
i was i was younger obviously so
i wasn't i was as mature as i am now
so i would have had that conversation
very differently now but it doesn't
matter
but um i went to perth saw some friends
i didn't have anyone around me that was
close to me that could actually
understand
the closest person was her and her
family i want to go back just a little
bit so you're
very insulated in this situation
you're in a relationship that you've
decided is wrong
you don't necessarily have any one or
many people
to support you in that decision what got
you
over that inertia of getting to say
the words because i think that is an
element that a lot of people get stuck
on maybe more guides to girls
they just see them as so fragile even
though they're not they would be much
they would be absolutely fine dealing
with it they'd be upset but they would
get over it
but i think guys speaking from personal
experience a lot of the time i i'll
obsess
over the breakup conversation because
i'm so terrified that it's going to
destroy them
first off it's like incredibly egotistic
to believe that you
you leaving their life is going to
absolutely destroy them for the rest of
their lives it's like
they will get over you it might take a
little while but they will get over you
and secondly i just think it it it kind
of
it stops us it stopped me for a long
time
from having a conversation that i knew
that i needed to have so i'm fascinated
as to you
how you as someone who didn't have that
support structure
found the courage to say it bro
it was like honestly i was like crying i
couldn't breathe
like i couldn't breathe bro i was like
the words weren't coming out my mouth
you know it was mad and like she was
sitting next to me and she was like it's
okay you can
it's okay you can tell me and i was like
and i told her the worst bit is
that uh
that she's a good person and i knew it
would [ __ ] hit her hard
and i knew and i know
a lot of people have anxiety and all
that [ __ ] and i knew what sort of
outcome it would have for a certain
amount of time and i know how much it
would affect her more so than me
you know but don't get me wrong and i'll
say this loud and clear i didn't get a
boner for like three weeks mate i was so
depressed
you know my head was my head was gone my
head was gone you know
i couldn't function i've got to the
stage where
i was coming into pt and i couldn't even
i'm not i've realized at one session i'm
talking about my [ __ ] problems to my
client i said i need a week off i can't
be doing this i said this is bad service
this is although my clients loved me and
they they kept asking me if
i'm okay i just didn't want to be that
guy
so when i had that conversation going
back to that
i told her i said i don't want to get
married
i don't want to get married why i'm like
because it doesn't feel right it just
doesn't feel right
i'm like i'm sorry but i i wanna
there's a lot of things that i wanna
accomplish in my life and the truth is
i can't act freely with having the
pressure
of paying a mortgage worrying about
someone being home alone
worrying about how um
what they might think what their family
might think you know
worrying about oh let's all go on a
family holiday all the family oh
less kids let's go and a family i don't
want to [ __ ] do that i don't want to
do that man i don't want to come and
listen
to i don't want to do that you know i'm
just telling everyone that's listening
well
most of the guys that want to achieve
something that's what that's what it is
they don't want to go so don't force
people to do what they don't want to do
because it ends up in shambles you know
and i said it like that and obviously
listen and any couple any person that's
listening to this no matter how much you
think that person loves you
no matter how much you think their
decision
everything they do is for you it's a
[ __ ] lie
everything that most people do
and what they should do is for their
self right me being there and being
there for that person is gonna make them
happy so that's why they want me there
right and you have to calculate that in
your head
and yeah it's maybe a bit egotistic but
the truth is
you have a value which is why
they like you so much and if you're not
getting that
back then it's a [ __ ] contract to be in
you know what i mean i always think
about it i always think about it like
getting on a roller coaster so before
you get into a
relationship with someone you're kind of
watching from the outside you obviously
only know a little bit it's like you
stood in the line
and then you watch a little bit of the
roller coaster go by and you're like
holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] that looks so exciting look
at all the turns
everyone's having a great time it looks
so exciting and new and different
and then if you wait in line for ages
and finally get yourself into a
relationship to find out that it's like
the little lady bird ride
that the three-year-olds get to go on
and it's just a loop that does the same
thing all the time it does exactly what
you want that's not why you waited in
line
and if it is what you wanted if you
waited in line to get on that particular
roller coaster looking at it being
exciting
in an effort to wrangle it down and turn
it into the lady bird ride
then that's not really a very successful
foundation
to build a relationship on it's not man
and the problem is
your happiness my happiness shouldn't be
relied on someone else making me happy
which is the biggest problem
right and it puts pressure on both
parties it puts pressure on
uh the person that um
has to kind of keep them happy that's
what happened you make me so happy you
complete me that's [ __ ] [ __ ] bro
it's [ __ ]
but it annoys me so much when i see this
online i'm like you're lying
stop commenting under that picture
because you're sitting next to her
say it to her face bro don't say i love
you on the picture say it to her face
man
we see it already you know and i'm so
like
passionate about this because i see
through [ __ ]
right and i just can't help call it out
and my friends are like doing no no
you're just it's from your experience
i'm not it's not from my experience but
yeah obviously from my experience i've
learned
but i can see it i can see it if the
part if you whoever you're seeing is not
happy with what they're doing
and their whole happiness is relied on
yourself then
um at some point it's gonna crash
i think you need to find a
best friend that loves what they're
doing you love what you're doing
you can have fun together there's no
pressure between each other
you know and you bring it together like
that if
one party or the other party relies on
you for happiness i just think it ends
up
i think it ends up in shambles and i'm
not listen i'm not a
relationship expert i'm not but i i
think i'm quite smart with
reading into not reading into people but
seeing things and
after experiencing things i have a
better idea of things you know i don't
want to come across as this oh who the
[ __ ] is this relationship guru
i'm not not a relationship coach
think about what that sentence says you
complete me
the converse of that is i am incomplete
without you
that's not right that's not the way that
it should be so i
i had daniel sloss netflix comedian who
did jigsaw
he has a tally of how many breakups and
divorces he's his
specials caused on his uh twitter bio
and um in that he says people will
prefer to choose
a partner who is a terrible fit than be
alone
he also says that you need to learn to
love yourself before you can let
somebody else love you
and he also says that the vast majority
of people don't choose someone who's
right
they choose someone who's there and when
you combine all of those things together
all of which i think are perfectly true
yeah that with pressures from
mum dad their side your side my mates
got married or why don't we move in we
should get engaged it doesn't surprise
me
i think the divorce rate's like 65
at the moment so more than half of the
marriages that begin
end in separation why
i don't i don't honestly like again i'm
not being auntie but i'm not trying to
be negative
the positive guy here is not trying to
be negative but like
when you sign a contract to get married
right
right how is that [ __ ] different what
are you treating them differently how
like if you're treating them differently
after you sign a contract to say that
you're married then that is wrong
you know like it shouldn't make a
difference at all
all it does it gives the other party
safety and safety
in my eyes is
it's not good i don't think it's healthy
i feel like you don't need to be on your
toes but you need to be
to keep the spice in it you got to keep
the spice somehow and
when people get comfortable when it's
like yep the old ball and chain and
that's it you know
we're together forever but no
you tell someone that you're getting
this forever
the work rate is going to drop you know
what i mean imagine all right chris
imagine if they said to you
hey your sponsor said to you we're going
to be paying you forever
your podcasts episodes will probably go
down you might naturally get lazy
you might because you're guaranteed for
life now bro
you know so what's the point of putting
more effort in you know
and it just it upsets me because i see
so many friends
with such potential to like do
amazing things and it's not their
partner stopping them it's them stopping
them you know it's their self stopping
their cells
and again this isn't me if you have
listen if you have the right person
there for you then you can achieve a lot
of things
don't get me wrong like i'm not trying
to say you can't achieve anything being
in a relationship i'm not saying that at
all
all i'm saying is you shouldn't base
decisions
and you should be happy on your own
first because when i first did what i
had to do and i moved out i got kicked
out my flat
yeah i got kicked out here there's a
madness like get the [ __ ] out of that
i was like
okay when that happened and i found a
new place on my own
families in london i've got friends in
sydney but it's family's different right
first time i moved in i moved all my
stuff in but i sat down and i cried
brother
that was the first time i was alone i
was alone
but i'm since 17 now 25. yeah i was
alone
i was alone i was sitting down i was
alone but i was alone in the room i had
no one to text
you know i had no one to text i had no
instagram followers either
so there was no dms coming through chris
there was no dms there was no dms coming
through
and so i was like [ __ ] i was like
this is [ __ ] bro i know what i'm gonna
do i'm gonna go get my knee up 24 7.
and but then i enjoyed my own company
and since then
i love my own space i love my whole
space like i love it i love it i love my
whole space
and yeah so that's that yeah you can
imagine there's a different world
a different universe where durian
doesn't have that conversation
where durham's still in a relationship
he's now living in
perth or sydney or adelaide two kids
maybe
house mortgaged up to the eyes but it
makes
it scares me a little bit it scares me a
little bit it scares me
because i didn't i didn't do to what
most typical people do from 17 to 25 i
didn't do it
so i felt like i missed out you know i
felt like i didn't make the mistakes i
didn't do stupid things
you know and again it's not even like
don't get me wrong man it's
when i talk about freedom i'm not
talking about trying to go bang
everything that i see
i'm not talking about that i'm talking
about going i'm booking a [ __ ] flight
today and i'm off because i don't have
to answer to no one
you know that's what i'm talking about i
don't want people to misunderstand that
i'm not trying to
that that if you're doing it for that
then i think it's the wrong reason and
if you want i guess you can but like
i'm not saying it for that reason i want
to make that clear i have a buddy
who was big big into pickup artistry for
a long time and was doing day game and
night game and
sleeping with a bunch of girls and stuff
and i remember asking him i was like
[ __ ] hellman like you're really
you're really passionate about pick a
part history
he's like yeah man like my future wife's
gonna be so thankful
i'm like okay i i can't wait
to see you try and justify this one to
me of how your future wife's going to be
thankful that you're
shagging literally everything he's like
well think about it man
i'm 45 years old and i'm walking down
the street holding my wife's hand we've
got our two kids in the stroller
and a brazilian chick walks past i don't
want to think
in the back of my mind i wonder what
it's like to [ __ ] a brazilian chick
i want to know and i want to i want to
tick off
all of the different sexual desires that
i have all of the different adventure
desires that i have
and i wonder whether now
we've still got quite a classic model
for relationships people
look at someone who's 30 or in their 30s
and still single and it's still a little
bit like
all right mate like [ __ ] good timing
but the you know the clock's ticking a
little bit if you were to look at wider
society overall
but we also have this wonderlust
entrepreneurial garyvee hustle and grind
go and get it you can make anything of
yourself that you want world
so we have we have this very traditional
world for relationships smashing up
against this
very new wave world for careers
those those two things don't combine and
i wonder how much that's contributing to
this current
dissatisfaction and divorce rate that
we're seeing in in relationships
bro i'm not gonna lie that when i sold
my story when i told my story first on
like my podcast
um i had so many messages saying dude i
just broke up with my partner
oh my holy [ __ ] i was like oh [ __ ] i was
like why because
what you said is exactly how i'm feeling
and i was like well good for you then
you know i mean you gotta do what's best
for you you know and that's and that's
the truth you've got to do what's best
for you and you've got to be selfish
and even if you have a family kids go
make sure you're happy
before you make the kids happy you know
i mean there's a reason when you're on a
flight they give you you get the oxygen
first right
so i think that's how you should look at
it if i'm being honest
i agree yeah uh have you changed your
mind on anything
this year have i changed my mind on
anything
uh that's a good question you know i
like that prompt that's a sick question
have i changed my mind on anything
i think i've stopped biting back at
trolls as much
why because it's a waste of [ __ ]
time it's a waste of time man and i've
realized like what's the point of
wasting my energy to that when i can
use it for more useful things you know
when it's
when the time is right i still bite back
when i need to for a message
but i don't buy it back as much as i
used to
and um my manager had a conversation
with me once after i saw something that
really frustrated me and i wanted to
fight back and i wanted to like i wanted
to go hard on this troll but he was like
nah
what's the point and he he kind of
dropped me a few words and i was like
you know what you're right
what's the point of me even wasting my
energy to this when i can use it for
good you know so
i think that's one thing i've changed my
mind on this year i'm a lot more chilled
with um trolls that come at me
which isn't that that many actually but
when they come they come pretty solid
there's a a point that you get to in
terms of exposure
where you start to attract a little bit
of
criticism online and then obviously that
goes right up to the
the full deep trolling and um
there's no training course on that like
you know you just kind of get dropped
into it yeah maybe that's part of the
price that you have to pay if you want
to have
a platform and you want to build up a
brand or
whatever yeah but it's not like
it's not like someone as soon as you get
blue ticked or as soon as you get to 100
000 subs on youtube or whatever it is
it's like someone just arrives with a
media pack that helps you to deal with
the
inevitable increased criticism that
you're going to get
and i think um i definitely think that
letting it go is a good one man so if
that's something that you've learned
from this year i think that's a
a pretty good lesson to take away and
it's going to make your life much easier
so
what about next year is there anything
that you're going to improve on anything
that you're going to work on yourself
personally
next year um i want to make uh
my project x product i want to i want to
be the best i want to be the best
accountability platform as a coach
online and i'm going to make it it's
going to happen
like there's no other way about it's
going to happen i'm going to make sure
people i want to make sure i can get my
message across to as many people
as possible to help them with
not only their not only their health but
their mindset as well
and i think if you have okay i i
don't like i don't like the word
influence of it like who gives a [ __ ]
we influence people right we've got the
power to influence people
i feel like if i don't do that as much
as i can
i feel like it's a bit of a waste so
that's my goal my goal for next year is
to get my message
across as many people as possible uh
whether it's my podcast whether it's my
um
program whether it's uh live events uh
i wanna be able to talk and get myself
out there as much as possible and travel
more
got to get kobe got to get covered out
the way first man i i really like it you
know to
it's a pleasure watching you and james
and and paul and the rest of the guys
kind of go on this little journey i
think it's a cool
it's a cool little community we've got a
lower spread across the world you know
like sunny and james are over there me
you and yeah everybody else is stuck in
the uk at the moment
but um yeah yeah i think it's i think
it's nice and
like again one of the best things that i
think's happened within the last two to
three years
has been this movement toward
how would you say realistic
effective training and diet you remember
like
five to ten years ago where it was
bodybuilding.com and it was kind of just
everything was bro science even the
science was bro science
and now now it's much more about how can
we
make sure that you're compliant make
sure that you're integrating your
training plan make sure that you're
doing it every single day that you're
sticking to your rules
and it permits you to have a life you're
not trying to be a [ __ ] professional
athlete you do not need to be eight
percent body fat
and here is 2 000 pieces of content from
different people across the world
telling you that that's the case and i
think um i think that movement
like long may it continue man you know
as someone who's been in and out of the
fitness world for a long time
i think it's a really really good
movement so yeah anyone
wants to find out more about you where
should they go what do you want to plug
oh um you'll find me darren cartel on
instagram
it's al with the cartel not el uh
if you need me www.darrencartel.com i've
got my podcast the dear and cartel show
you can find it everywhere
and yeah that's it really youtube all
over if you search here on kato anyway
you'll see me
um bro thank you for having me on man
it's been a pleasure i really enjoyed
this one you ask
really good questions thank you man
until next time we'll we'll have to plan
another trip out to dubai
100 bro
you